ja und wir beginnen gleich mit
grauenvollen nachrichten die uns aus dem
landkreis kusel in rheinland pfalz
erreichen in der nacht waren zwei junge
polizeibeamte dort auf einer
routinemäßigen streifenfahrt unterwegs
bei einer verkehrskontrolle um 24 wurden
sie dann völlig unvermittelt durch
schüsse tödlich verletzt die genauen
hintergründe der tat sind noch unklar
die polizei fahndet jetzt mit hochdruck
nach den flüchtenden tätern und ist am
tatort mit der sicherung von spuren
beschäftigt eine beschreibung der täter
oder des fluchtfahrzeuges liegen bislang
nicht vor und auch die fluchtrichtung
die ist nicht bekannt der tatort die
kreisstraße 22 ist im bereich mai weiler
hof und mit voll gesperrt weil die
polizei die bitte die bevölkerung im
landkreis kusel keine anhalter
mitzunehmen zeugen die etwas
verdächtiges wahrgenommen haben werden
jetzt gebeten sich mit der polizei in
kaiserslautern in verbindung zu setzen
bild reporter thorsten kraemer ist für
uns live vor ort in kusel thorsten wie
ist die lage vor ort was kannst du uns
sagen
dort haben sie es so aus dass sie ja an
der kreisstraße die polizei weiträumig
absperren eingerichtet hat ich befinde
mich direkt an der einfahrt in richtung
mettmann sind hinter mir die
polizeiautos den straßen blockieren
polizisten sind hier auch unterwegs mit
maschinenpistolen und schusssicheren
westen also es ist höchste
alarmbereitschaft angesagt auch auf den
zufahrtsstraßen zogen ulm at bzw
auch zwischen autobahnen wurzeln schon
habe ich auf dem weg hierhin sehr viele
polizeiwagen gesehen ziemlich autos die
hier mit blaulicht unterwegs sind und
auch weitere fahrzeuge die straße stehen
der oder die täter sind flüchtig die
menschen im landkreis wurden ja auch
dazu aufgerufen jetzt niemanden per
anhalter mitzunehmen und ähnliches kann
man die angst in der bevölkerung
tatsächlich spüren
zur bevölkerung selber hatte ich jetzt
noch keinen kontakt das war keine zeit
gewesen aber man hat schon
hier sehr bemüht
einmal aufzuklären
spezialeinheiten wie gesagt sind noch
nicht zu sehen dem lesen argentinischen
wir machen den polizisten ich habe
gerade hier eine einsatzstelle auch
gesehen dass die ermittler eingetroffen
sind
hier natürlich auch in der
spurensicherung beschäftigt sind deshalb
ist es momentan auch wichtig diese
straße abzusperren um hier nicht
irgendwelche spuren zu verwischen
hat die polizei inzwischen neue
erkenntnisse was kannst uns zum
aktuellen ermittlungsstand der polizei
sagen
ja momentan sieht es so aus hier an der
einsatzstelle selber halten sich die
beamten bedeckten verweisen auf die und
direktionsleiter die hier
übernommen hat von dort aus werden auch
weitere informationen denke ich mal
folgen allerdings ein durchkommen nach
kaiserslautern ist momentan schwierig
denn da laufen die telefone derzeit
sturm
dankeschön für diese ganz aktuellen
informationen und wir wollen jetzt noch
einmal zusammenfassen was wir genau zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt wissen also zwei
junge polizisten eine 24 jährige und ein
29-jähriger für einem landkreis kusel
eine routinemäßige verkehrskontrolle
durch auf der kreisstraße 22 fallen dann
gegen 4 uhr 20 schüsse auf die beamten
die polizisten konnten noch eine funk
meldung absetzen hilfe kam für sie aber
zu spät die hintergründe sind bislang
noch völlig unklar mindestens ein täter
ist bewaffnet die polizei ist gerade
noch mit der spurensicherung beschäftigt
und fahndet mit hochdruck nach den
flüchtigen tätern könnte aber schwer
werden denn es gibt keine näheren
beschreibung zu den tätern zum fahrzeug
oder aber auch zu der fluchtrichtung und
die polizei die bitte darum im landkreis
kusel keine anhalter mitzunehmen
das hat die polizei wirklich noch mal
eindringlich gesagt und man soll eben
auch wenn man etwas verdächtiges gesehen
hat sich unbedingt bei der polizei
melden
es gibt auch eine telefonnummer die
daran gezeigt dass es die 0631 369 2620
das ist die polizei in kaiserslautern
mit der man sich in verbindung setzen
soll und wir werden natürlich auch
weiter berichten sobald es neue
erkenntnisse zu diesem fall gibt
erfahren sie alles hier bei uns bei bild